بات المشهد خطيرا من منطقه السرايا
وضبي وصولا الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي وجنوبا
الى منطقه الجوازات والجامعات وغربا الى
ميناء غزه البحري في هذه اللحظات تدور
اشتباكات ضاريه وانفجارات عنيفه في منطقه
السرايا ومنطقه الرمال قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيل تعمق اليوم الاحد من عدوانها
على هذه المناطق تقصف على مدار الساعه
تطلق
الرصاص يعني هذه المنطقه هي منطقه غرب
مدينه غزه كانت تحوي الاف او عشرات الاف
النازحين باتت هذه المنطقه مخلاه في رحله
نزوح كانت مؤلمه جدا بعض العائلات اجبرت
تحت وطاه الرصاص وتحت تهديد جنود الاحتلال
الى الذهاب الى منطقه النصيرات وسط مدينه
غزه نحاول
بشتى السبل ان نصل الى
المحاصرين في مجمع الشفاء
الطبي لكن هذا المفترق هو الاخطر الذي
يمكن ان نتجاوزه باذن الله عز
وجل يجب ان تكون الحركه سريعه كون كونها
محاصره تماما من ال الصاط الاسرائيليه كما
تشاهدون هذا الاطلاق المباشر للرصاص هو في
شارع مجمع الشفاء الطبي ونؤدي الى بوابته
وصلنا الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي بعد رحله
كانت مليئه بالمخاطر والرصاص والقذائف
هؤلاء المحاصرين بداخله لليوم السابع على
التوالي دون ان يجدوا ماء او غذاء لا اكل
ولا ميه ولا دواء ولا علاج ولا اي حاجه
يعني حتى الاطفال مش ملايين لهم اكل ولا
شرب انهم يعني نوفر لهم اياه ما فيش خالص
ما فيش خالص والله العظيم بتتمنى تتمنى
تلاقي ربع رغيف في طمين البنت اه ما فيش
خالص نهائيا لا سائل ولا مسؤول لا اكل ولا
ميه ولا
مصاري يعني الواحد ماش يشتري شيء طالعين
تحت الطاخ مننا ربنا ياخذ الروح ونخلص من
الحدوته مشين مش قادرين نطلع بره هي باب
الشفا وهي المجمع الناس بتلف قاعده ورا
بعض ورا بعض بتلفلف الناس وين نروح مش
عارفين لمين نشكي نشكي بس لله في هذه
اللحظات تطلق قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المناشير هذه المناشير التي دائما تحمل
عبارات تهديد للمواطنين تسقط مباشره في
ساحه مجمع الشفاء الطبي يحاول هنا الاهالي
المحاصرين ان يقراوا ما بداخلها تشاهدون
هذا تهديد جديد ال الى كل من يتواجد في
غرب غزه يعني الاحتلال يصر على ترحيل
الاهالي هنا المحاصرين تحت وطاه الدبابات
الاسرائيليه الى منطقه دير البلح هذه
المنطقه في المناطق الوسطى حرام علينا وين
نروح ما يخلينا محاصرين في المستشفى
تطلعوا لا بدنا نطلع خلينا نموت هان مصرين
يا مصرين هنا اه مصرين الرب الموته واحده
والرب واحد يعني الحصار موجود هي اطلاق
النار موجود واحنا سامينه لكن مش قادرين
نطلع من داخل
المستشفى هذه غارتان
متتاليتان استهدفت بها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذه المنطقه الاهالي الان
يفرون من هذه المنطقه ولا نعلم ان كانت
قد تركت شهداء او جرحه وين ايش مالك خايف
ايش الضوا ضربوه في ق صف شيء في مصابين
شيء
لا هذه هي الاوضاع في غرب مدينه غزه يعني
الاحتلال يطالب الاهالي هنا بالخروج ويقصف
في تجمعاتهم بالقذائف وبطائق الاستطلاع كل
يوم بيرموا علينا مناشير على اساس انه
نحنا نخلي ونطلع من المنطقه وهذه منطقه
عسكريه وكلكم عص شارع الرشيد وشارع البحر
وال هي الدبابات هناك بيستنوا الناس تمشي
من غاد عشان تطخ عليها يعني بدهم يعدموه
والي اه اعدام كامل واليوم لما حولت وصلت
دوار حيدر وغلطت دوار حيدر في حدود زي 50
متر لقيت الدبابه قدامي وجراف نفس امبارح
ما تراجعت ولا لحظه وعمال جاي اجري جراي
انا من المنطقه هذك لما وصلت الشفاء يدرك
الاهالي جيدا ان الخروج من مجمع الشفاء
الطبي الى منطقه دير البلح في المحافظه
الوسطى انها ستكون رحله مليئه بالتفتيش
والاعدامات لذلك هم يصرون على البقاء في
شمال قطاع غزه بهاجر احنا بدنا نضلنا في
بلادنا نموت في بلادنا ونحيا في بلادنا و
ونعيش في بلادنا وما بدناش نروح مطرح
يتساءل النازحون هنا عن اليوم الذي سيفك
به حصارهم من مجمع الشفاء الطبي ويتخوفون
من ان تدخل الدبابه الاسرائيليه الى
باحاته مجددا وتجبرهم قصرا وتحت التهديد
بالقتل الى الهجره الى دير البلح احنا
بنطالب الدول العربيه تقف بسرعه معان
طلعنا من الحرب والكرب احنا يعني تعبنا
تعبنا كل بيوتنا مهدمه طبنا بدنا نخلص
بدنا نرجع لابواب لبيوتنا بدنا ناكل بدنا
نشرب بدنا نرجع لبيوتنا نقعد على على
الركام بدنا نقعد فوق الدور وهي مكسره بس
نروح ونخلص بنطالب وقف اطلاق النار ونخلص
هالمرحله اللي احنا
فيها